just to remind people here perhaps
haven't seen other alien videos with you
Brian so he worked at Bell Labs and a
TMT I mean you didn't research that you
were looking for the future how right we
had one weekend he closed yeah so I was
at AT&T I went there for a couple
summers starting in the in the late
1960s and I stayed there essentially
full-time until 2000 I was in Bell Labs
so at the time 18 T was a very big
company it was well over a million
people was the biggest company in the
country and it provided communication
services telephone for essentially all
of the United States and Bell Labs was
the research arm of that so that's
apartment theory is looking at the
future trying to improve the services
that they have and in build the
technology in all kinds of ways that
will make it easy for or we make it
possible to improve telecommunications
services and so 18 he did things like
the transistor in the laser and
miscellaneous other things that were
useful and also a lot of computing
related things as they gradually
realized that computers were here to
stay and that a lot of mechanical things
like relays and so on could be replaced
by electronic devices and been
controlled by programs on running on
general-purpose computers in some sense
the Golden Age for me was probably the
1970s I had just gotten out of school
and with the early days of computing
there were a lot of really interesting
work going on and that was when UNIX was
developed early 1970s and the C
programming language and a variety of
other things in insulting when I played
with programming languages as well so
that was definitely good time sort of
behind your question I think as well so
how good were you at seeing the future
and the answer is pretty awful I think
most of you are pretty awful at seeing
the future and I'm quite I could hardly
deny it so I'm perfectly willing to
admit it I don't think we had and I
wouldn't say all my colleagues and
friends at bellas had much of a clue of
how the world would change we I guess
knew about Moore's law Moore's law I
think came from I think he published
that paper in 1965 based on a fair
a short period of data like maybe five
years and I don't think certainly not I
but I don't think many people realize
the implications of an exponential rise
in capability at a fixed price if
applied for 4050 years I don't think we
realized any of that so nobody believed
it Lily took it that seriously for this
data time I I don't know where I would
say nobody believes it but I don't think
people realize the implications and I
certainly I did not realize the
implications and we were I think often
surprised when we discovered it
something we had done had actually been
noticed in the outside world I remember
at one point Dennis Ritchie saying to me
something like we have arrived because
he had found in the New York Times which
was still running classified ads for
programmers they'd not wanted a
programmer who knew UNIX and this was I
will guess in maybe late 70s or
something like that and this was us boy
what we've done has actually had some
influence in the outside world in a way
that was completely unpredictable so
there's one key thing called the that
that you think should've made it but
didn't kind of put me on the spot any so
yeah that's definitely on the spot I
it's hard to say one gets the feeling
that a lot of things that were obvious
to us have been kind of lost in going
forward one unix the operating system
see the programming language many of the
tools those all had a flavor of
minimality of being small and compact
and good for their particular purpose
and not with too many bells and whistles
and very carefully written and so on and
as Moore's Law came along and we got
more and more processing power and more
and more memory capacity people sort of
forgot the merits of simplicity perhaps
and so things became rather more baroque
or Rococo or picture architectural
period and I think that that is in some
ways to everyone's detriment that
systems are very complicated the other
thing is that at one point there was
really only one let's call it UNIX
system and so things are fairly
compatible and in the
the thing that I think we've lost is
compatibility that it's harder to get
things to work together perhaps than it
was but in some ways perhaps as
necessary you think the big change in a
lot of things has been the rise of
networking the idea that computers are
not self-contained things anymore but
rather they are devices that talk to
other devices using a variety of
networking technology internet itself
and of course increasingly phones the
phone system and in fact there's no real
difference between the phone system and
the Internet in some sense it's kind of
an accidental separation that will
disappear over time and as different
things talk to each other it the what
happens there gets more and more
complicated there more ways that things
can break you need standards but the
standards are necessarily there and so
yeah I think that's the place where we
need the most improvement in some sense
is ways to make things work better
together and make them simpler and I
guess those are related I think there's
a there's kind of analogy as well that
you've got this massive phone company
effectively pushing forward on computer
technology and now the many computer
people uses the phone is that pocket yes
right I think that's again something
that people didn't predict there's a
famous story that a consulting company
in the United States McKinsey did a
study for AT&T and told AT&T that there
was basically no market for cell phones
that people didn't want portable phones
and this I think is a triumph of how
consultancy can go wrong and yet not
suffer for it and he said but AT&T
didn't back that stuff as well a lot of
the early work on mobile telephony was
done at AT&T
absolutely they figured out this the
notion of cells and how you would pass
conversations from one cell to another
something that's completely invisible to
people today but all of that was in fact
invented originally at AT&T and then of
course he vault tremendously by other
people over the years and again cell
phones today profit from Moore's law
that you've got incredible power in a
very very compact device would not have
been possible
thirty years earlier I'm the lastingly
school is son Cruz okay it's hard to say
you're hinting that people don't use
their phones to talk and I think that
that's true as far as I can tell
students that I deal with in the United
States use their phones primarily for
texting each other and perhaps for
checking their Facebook pages or
whenever the modern equivalent is and
this is so foreign to me that I don't
actually know how to use a phone in many
ways I had an extended discussion with
Dave earlier this morning about how you
deal with with phone numbers and whether
you need a 44 and not a zero or is it
hopeless
um that was the reason I had trouble
communicating with him this morning so
culture shock in some sort of way and
what I do is I take pizza and I run it
through a hash which scrambles it up in
some way and produces a number which is
between zero and in this case let's call
it and okay so the hashing